all right so what do you have on your
head
talk to my wife don't look at me she
just comes in she you're like a puppy
that she dresses I parently I'm supposed
to be Susan strong yeah hey yeah you can
me out that's great
another great contribution okay so this
is beautifu and this is another Susan
strong episode only the second one right
that she's bad and then they got a road
it's like it builds up all this even
more mystery and it's like dammit um
this episode is she comes in and says
that that tells Finn and Jake that she
needs help
stopping the with the gloves for love
gloves love love gloves gloves which I'm
wondering that's a reference to return
the Jedi cuz anyone wears the original
knows the ending song yo go home
Oh was it no no yo yo yo no okay they
sound eerily similar but yeah
nevertheless oh yeah you rather saw part
of the Ewoks yeah it was a horrible
solid turn of the Jedi okay um all right
so she says that she needs how then
needs the fire the red flower a tree
like that vodka playing reference there
and they bring it down to their
underground dystopia and they have to
like this flame to get rid of the lumps
got that sort of gloves love gloves
sounds like love handles so this sounds
like melting love handles um and there's
enough you to stretch just like the real
change
yeah
oh he's an ass I don't like him anymore
you want to stay because I'm do I wanted
to take you seriously with that it has
no eyes that's what's so creepy of that
okay we're really good sidekick alright
so they go and they defeat these things
that look like just pool pool toys but
then they transform these pretty
cool-looking demons I thought those are
pretty awesome specially the way the
teeth were designed and stuff like that
uh they they said a fire they get rid of
them all and people can go to this area
and they they have heat now and they can
set up whatever camp or whatever they do
and as they're leaving they don't know
Susan's a fish person or a human and she
takes fins hand puts it under her on
this and we don't know what he felt if
it was a gill or nothing and they just
gets on the boat walks off and that's it
sort of a badge cuz on the boats a whole
bunch of pretzels man you know okay it's
alright a lot of weird stuff but the
other really weird thing was that the
Jake can't sleep yeah reminds me of my
dad reminds me of my mom it's like just
these glump sub GUI and like one has a
million miles instead I'm like what and
it does that come in again shut on that
one okay III don't know how it comes I
guarantee it's just acting crazy or what
um but you know unlike the last one this
is another one that's the kind of slower
it's definitely slower but I think
because they do have the character they
have the mystery and the legit
atmosphere uh I think it's okay um and
you know it still got some good jokes in
there and the but quiet never to eat you
can knock over the camera okay gallery
is so easily distracted okay we but okay
yes I well your gang distracted you
getting distracted by her laugh and does
he you're looking over there so you
so yeah I like the I like the build up I
like the mystery I like the you know
just raising more questions and I think
the the only thing I thought was kind of
weird isn't me was the music a little
odd in this one I know this house where
cuz it's always kind of weird but like
something that really stood out in this
one like it didn't sound like normal
like a normal score it was like it's
somewhere synthy or awkward or I don't
know do you know what I'm talking about
well especially the scene where they get
to be the beautopia if you will and the
first love glove comes out something
like I said love glove ya know that love
comes out and it's just weird over the
top kind of like synth like creepy yeah
it's kind of distracting yeah I wouldn't
say it's distracting it was just it was
just weird like you for me I was like oh
god what's coming like it was kinda like
that build up in you know it's like oh
crap what's coming you know but I did
you know I could see the the whatever
the pool toys we're gonna you know
attack and they were actually gonna be
dangerous at that by like how oh yeah
they day you know I thought like just it
was gonna open its mouth like her beak
or whatever and just bite Jake or
something like I like that they opened
up and there's these kind of smoke
demons yeah I thought that was really
cool um so yeah what'd you think I
didn't like it as much as you did
no um it was okay Susan strong is a fine
character but it's kind of one of those
mysteries quote-unquote that like
they're gonna drag out and drag out and
try you and you're never gonna find out
or if you do it's not gonna be for like
five seasons later now uh if Susan is
human or not and yeah you can take the
way that fin reacts whereas wide-eyed
and then after it feels he goes small
eyes where it's like oh my god are you
oh no you're not or oh my god oh my god
okay now I know yeah I mean that could
be like yeah yeah and that's my thing
it's like it's like romances in cartoons
or kids shows you know I'm just gonna
say that where they drag it out and it
just it gets old after a while it's like
I loved Wolverine the comic book that is
when you know
didn't know his origin but when they
started like filling in the blank spots
for the origin it's like okay that's
pretty cool ladies started filling in
more spots making it more complicated
and it just got annoying it's like don't
tell me anything or tell me all at once
just don't drag it out either way
well here it's kind of the opposite
they're not telling you much they're
telling you more that just somebody
knows but that's what I'm saying it's
like either tell me all of it one should
get it done and over with or just don't
tell me at all stop tossing in these
little tiny things where it's like well
but the whole show serve works in a way
they you know very slowly it'll reveal
certain things that they've revealed it
all at once you know I don't know that B
is fun I think for me though it's that
they're not revealing much it's a little
it's too little yeah you know a little
is fine but this is too little okay no
I'll agree with that okay like going
back to like the Marceline episodes and
all that stuff they're revealing stuff
and it's nice the I think you know what
you hit it on the head with the amount
or the lack of amount that they're
showing you know they're not giving
enough to keep me interested with the
Marceline episodes definitely they were
giving just enough to keep me interested
in want to know more but not to the
point where I'm like I'm bored now yeah
yeah no I did like the inner-tube
monsters yeah and I actually and the one
other thing I'll mention we're talking
about the music when Jake starts singing
that song on the raft like it actually
stopped at just the right moment cuz I
was just about to say this is really
stupid and they stabbed her in the
middle song said this is really stupid
okay that's good timing on that so um
yes any closing remarks um no don't you
have a cat head and a dog body as I make
you cat dog yeah but where do I poop
from I mean that is a good question up
for cat dog where does he poop from that
leaves a dog mouth nice does he poop
bought the cat mouth well if the cat
eats does he poop up the dog's mouth and
on top of that where do they pee I never
get a look at Naruto's but the same way
again thank you for that
no problem